welcome back to cbs saturday morning we
begin this half hour with new insight
and potentially damaging testimony at
the next round of hearings investigating
the deadly january 6th riot at the
capitol former white house counsel pat
sipoloni whose name has been mentioned
throughout the hearings spoke with house
committee members for nearly eight hours
on friday scott mcfarland has more on
the high stakes testimony
outside the meeting room pat cipoloni
wouldn't answer reporters questions did
you discuss pardons sir and members of
congress who asked for them but the big
question is how much did he answer
inside in a day-long session with the
house january 6 committee more than a
week after he was subpoenaed and after
former white house aide cassidy
hutchinson testified scipoloni warned on
january 6 trump would face criminal
exposure if he went to the capitol we're
going to get charged with every crime
imaginable committee members told cbs
news they expected sipoloni to testify
about what he witnessed firsthand
january 6. is it
tricky for a white house counsel to
answer questions from a congressional
panel it is very
very tricky richard painter was a member
of the white house counsel's office for
former president george w bush and said
cipolloni might invoke privilege if
asked directly about warning trump about
possible crimes
this is a very difficult situation
that congress will have to handle uh
with a substantial amount of delicacy in
order to get the information that they
need
without invading unduly on the
attorney-client privilege meanwhile
police in virginia have just released
body camera video of the search on the
home of trump justice department
official jeffrey clark last month can i
call my lawyer sure come on outside and
do it clark has also been a focus of the
january 6 committee amid allegations he
was part of an attempted 11th hour
shakeup in the justice department which
would have made him the acting u.s
attorney general he was the focus of a
previous committee hearing the justice
department wouldn't comment on the
search the committee's next hearing is
set for tuesday and it will focus on the
mobilization of the mob including by far
right groups and domestic violent
extremists
for cbs saturday morning i'm scott
mcfarland at the capitol